hello everybody a very good morning to
you it's seven o'clock you're very
welcome to join us wherever you're
watching us
right around the world this morning an
unsettled outlook home and away we'll
have the latest as storm dudley burst
down across scotland and northern
england meanwhile the u.s forecasts the
tensions far from over is casting doubt
on russian claims of a troop withdrawal
from the ukraine border in a moment
we'll speak to the chair of the defense
select committee tobias elwood he's in
kiev plus the armed forces minister
james heapey he joins us after eight
o'clock it's thursday the 17th of
february
thousands wake up without power and face
travel disruption in the north of
england and in scotland after storm
dudley pummeled the uk and there's more
bad weather to come
no withdrawal the us says russia has
added several thousand troops along
ukraine's border despite claims it was
pulling back some soldiers
the foreign secretary warns russia could
draw out the crisis for months ahead of
a visit to ukraine and to other european
allies
i'm in brussels where defence ministers
are planning their next move as a
standoff with moscow continues
hospitals the overwhelmed coronabiaris
patients are treated outdoors as hong
kong faces record infections despite a
zero covert policy
deliver some justice a group of cross
party mps demand fair compensation for
the victims of the post office scandal
terror in the tides sydney's beaches are
closed and people are ordered to stay
out of the water after the city's first
fatal shark attack in almost 60 years
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning
the end of an era one of the uk's oldest
zoos is set to shop for good we'll speak
to bristol zoo about why it's closing
and how it'll keep the animal magic
alive
and just the ticket will speak to a hero
bus driver and the passenger whose life
he saved
[Music]
good morning everybody storm eunice has
packed a punch with strong winds and
heavy rain overnight causing power cuts
and travel disruption across large parts
of scotland and northern england
northern powgrid says more than 14 000
homes lost electricity with 4 000 yet to
be reconnected in parts of yorkshire
lancashire cumbria and in the northeast
42 flood alerts are in place mostly
clustered around yorkshire the welsh
borders and the midlands
and there's a major disruption on the
railways including all services in
scotland where it could be midday before
trains start running on some routes
standing by for fraser this morning hi
fraser i think you're in york this
morning aren't you how's it going there
good morning kay i am in york yeah i'm
in clifton next to the riverus which is
one of the places where these 42 flood
alerts are in place at the moment two
flood warnings in place over in cumbria
as well and it feels as though we're in
the calm between the storms it was
really windy this morning a couple of
hours ago those winds have died down now
as storm dudley finally passes away but
we're waiting for storm eunice to come
in tonight uh overnight we saw winds of
over 80 miles an hour 81 miles an hour
in in north wales over 70 miles an hour
in west yorkshire are causing serious
disruption and power outages as well we
saw huge power outages problems with
storm irwin didn't we a few weeks ago
with tens of thousands of homes losing
their power but if we look at the
northern power grid interactive map of
of where is without power at the moment
few dotted red areas sparsely dotted
around the north of england uh ten
thousand homes had their power restored
overnight still four thousand without
their power but if you looked at that
map last night it was a sea of red there
was in fact a waiting system in place on
the website you had to be uh wait uh in
a queue to to be allowed to let on to
the website and then you were only
allowed 10 minutes to view the local
flood situation or the local power
outage situation in your area before you
were booted out but uh clearly they've
been working hard nor the power grid
they've got most of those homes back on
they're not sure yet how long it will
take to get those 4 000 homes that are
still without power back on the grid
again and of course as you mentioned uh
severe travel disruption as well if we
look uh up in scotland scotrail decided
to suspend most of their services from
four o'clock yesterday afternoon uh when
we saw lots of trees on the line and so
on more travel disruption uh coming
later on uh tomorrow as well people from
uh who've got tickets on the london
northeast railway saying that they can
use their tickets today rather than
tomorrow bracing ourselves for storm
eunice hundred mile an hour winds
preparing for the worst and hoping for
the best as always in these situations
indeed rosa thank you
in other news the united states has
accused russia of adding as many as 7
000 troops along the ukraine border in
recent days that's despite claims by
president putin that troops are being
pulled back from the region
western estimates suggest russia has
massed about 150 000 troops around
ukraine
satellite images taken over the last 48
hours show military forces deployed
along ukraine's border in belarus in
crimea and western russia a new military
pontoon bridge an attack helicopter unit
and artillery are among the elements
visible in the photographs
let's just take you through the latest
developments in the crisis should we
here we go the foreign secretary liz
tross will visit ukraine's capital kiev
in the coming days she's expected to
make a speech warning vladimir putin
that an invasion would bring severe
economic sanctions
ukraine's president has tweeted his
appreciation for the uk support and
thanked boris johnson for showing unity
with ukraine
elsewhere nato defense ministers are
meeting in brussels for a second day of
talks in an effort to avoid war
and ukraine has asked the u.n security
council to discuss a bid by russia's
parliament to recognize self-proclaimed
separatists when they meet later on
today
let's take you to kiev should we stand
by to speak to us this morning as the
chair of the defense select committee
and former defense minister of course
tobias elwood mr elwood thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
what are you hoping to achieve with your
visit
well firstly you get a flavor just how
serious the situation is there's
absolutely a real threat from russia
across the border that hasn't dissipated
as you were just outlining but there's
also a huge recognition and appreciation
for the support coming from britain
that's very very obvious indeed but the
penny is dropping too that ukraine is at
the epicenter if you like of the clash
between western liberalism and
authoritarianism there is a much bigger
picture at clay which i think the west
is now beginning to appreciate and if we
blink where could uh this uh take us
it's too late to bring in a nato
division as i call for i recognize that
but the west i think needs to ask
themselves what more
can we do perhaps look at a no-fly zone
certainly defense spending will have to
increase as the world does get more
dangerous but it's this bigger alliance
between russia and china it's through
that prism that we need to look at
events here in ukraine
did want to um i know that you are uh
quite close with lord donate you've been
speaking to him quite a lot over the
last few days given that you've been
you've brought up the troops there i
just wanted to play this grab to you
from what he said to us earlier on in
the week and see where that puts us now
here we go
i shouldn't smile um you're not the
first person to ask me um about
tomorrow's elbow but
actually i rang tobias about 20 minutes
ago and said come on chuck what are you
getting on about
and that was when we were talking of
course about troops on the ground in
ukraine
and particularly around kiev the capital
what would you say in response to him
well we did have a conversation and
we're actually saying the same thing
it's far too late i was calling for this
months and months ago when the build-up
of troops of russian troops uh was
evident uh there's a process that has to
be followed uh we need to take the
british people with us to recognize that
yes uh this is a high-risk strategy but
ultimately it would prevent an invasion
you're not starting a war you're
actually preventing a russian attack and
that must be a good thing nato is all
about european security and ukraine is
part of europe the consequences of not
doing anything allowing that evasion
invasion to actually take place will
have massive implications for the uk
economy oil gas food prices will go up
but like i said there's a bigger picture
at play at where russia is going its
alliance with china will is a turning
point if you like uh in our security on
the international stage and i think
privately the international community is
regretting not stepping forward but we
still can act we still can offer a
no-fly zone and critically this
initiative that britain has put forward
the last time the prime minister was
here this alliance between poland
ukraine and britain is something that's
very very important indeed that needs to
be explored as to how we can support the
ukrainian people if we do nothing and
allow an invasion to take place it will
have i think a totemic effect on
european security this is a serious
moment and uh we're being tested
lord dana also said that we shouldn't
allow ukraine to join nato the german
chancellor schultz who was in moscow as
you know speaking to president putin
this week he seemed to hint at that as
well where do you stand on that a bit
well we need to get over this idea that
we hide behind the excuse that because a
nation is not in nato that they don't
deserve some form of serious support
libya for example um kosovo uh bosnia
iraq afghanistan these are all places
that we went in as nato capability but
they're not members of nato but there
were security concerns here so we need
to stop hiding behind this the west has
become too risk-averse over the months
indeed the years itself i'd even call
for a casablanca type conference if you
like because you've got berlin paris
london and washington still looking in
slightly different directions and that's
being exploited
by putin in moscow
what's the casablanca conference
well this happened during the second
world war it was before you even decided
what you wanted to do you made sure that
the home team was pointing in the same
direction so yes we've threatened the
sanctions but if you understand the
bigger picture if
uh putin is wanting to realign his
country with china sanctions will only
help him persuade the russian people
look our future is not with the west
it's actually with china we don't need
that nordstrom 2 going across to the
western europe we can have three of
those with china and of course they have
scant regard for human rights issues and
so on
an equal disdain for the west and that
alliance as i say i can't be stronger in
what i'm my concerns here that new
alliance will have a massive implication
for geopolitical security over the next
few decades
there was a day of unity yesterday in uh
ukraine and kiev particularly some
concerns that yesterday was going to be
the day that there was an incursion and
invasion that didn't happen thankfully
um
but what's the mood there like as an
outsider as a westerner if you will what
are you picking up
well when you first come here you can
feel the tension there's no doubt about
it the threat is very very real indeed
but there's a stoic sense of
determination here don't forget the
people here have been living with this
for years and years and years with the
war going on but a crisis you know could
break out at any moment and uh
contingency plans are in place there is
an absolute worry and i think privately
there is a desire to you know call for
the west to do more this is their moment
of need and at the moment the west is
not doing enough
and doing more looks like what
well like i said initially a no-fly zone
would be held very very helpful indeed
that is something i hope that could be
explored at the munich security
conference certainly as each day goes by
and an invasion doesn't take place we
should be absolutely supporting um
ukraine as i say that bond between
poland uh ukraine and britain is
something that absolutely wants to be
explored that's something you can ask
james heapy about that alliance there
could be the genesis of uh and include
the baltics as well of a new strength of
support of security in eastern europe
but i i stress this is a the bigger
picture taking place here it's not just
about ukraine this is about global
security and where our world goes to as
our international rules-based order will
be reinterpreted by russia and china if
they form this axis over the coming
months and years
but you are stepping back now are you
miss del wood from uk boots on the
ground
i i made that very clear that that was
an option that option has departed we
simply cannot do that when i first
raised this at the end of last year yes
and speaking to military uh senior
military leaders uh in both in britain
and uh and the united states absolutely
it could have happened it would have
taken five days to actually mobilize
those forces at the request of ukraine
this is what they actually wanted to but
we blinked we didn't appreciate that
full picture we didn't have the
situational awareness to say my goodness
this is not just about ukraine there's
something else going on here the west is
now appreciating that there's no doubt
about it but i worry that still isn't
fully understood like i said any
sanctions that are imposed on to to
russia they will retaliate and it will
give putin the excuse to pivot his
country away from the west towards an
alliance with china
mr elwood uh it's good to talk to you
thank you for joining us this morning
thank you
thank you we'll also be hearing the
thoughts of the government this morning
as tobias always hinted that speaking to
the armed forces minister james heapey
at around 10 past eight
ms trust is heading to ukraine this week
to deliver a speech warning president
putin against invasion in a moment we'll
speak to our security and defense editor
deborah haynes who's in kiev but first
to ali who is standing by in brussels
where nato defense ministers are meeting
and have been for several days haven't
they um ali what have they achieved
morning kay um well they've they've set
out a potential plan to
change their posturing their military
posturing so the presence of troops in
parts of eastern europe which would be
significant it's not set in stone yet
but that was the significant
announcement that came yesterday evening
and this is day two and a particularly
significant day because it is a day that
the ukrainian
defense secretary is going to be here in
brussels meeting those 30 nato members
this is a routine meeting it happens
every six months but it is one that has
forced nato for the first time in a long
time to really focus on their own
defense and their own deterrence and i
think the big question is how long can
this go on for how long can this really
be drawn out this long protracted
standoff and we we heard some um some
about that yesterday from jen
stoltenberg talking about a new normal
the new uh normal being this constant
threat from russia and he talked about
the potential for battle groups moving
eastwards he said that france had
already indicated they would be willing
to host a battle group in romania but um
but we wait to see if that will actually
happen military commanders are going to
be looking at it clearly that is the
opposite of what president putin wants
he says his security concern is the
expansion of nato eastwards um but jen
stoltenberg nato's secretary general
says that this is defensive and that
they are still listening to russia's
security concerns and that they want
diplomacy to work
okay ali thank you
deborah stanley bye for us in kiev where
we saw um
the
chair of the defense committee just a
few moments ago um hello to you deborah
listening to tobias elwood there
he you can feel his frustration at the
fact that the west have not done enough
quickly enough
yes although there's been you know
there's this balancing act that nato
allies have been trying to perform
between defending themselves helping to
deter an attack on ukraine and not being
seen to be provocative to give
president putin an excuse to be able to
say well look my these allies these this
nato alliance is a threat to me which is
what he is saying but if you actually
saw nato troops here in ukraine
yes it would definitely increase the
deterrence effect yes it would enhance
ukraine's ability significantly to
defend itself but it would take you one
step closer to a direct confrontation
between russia and nato and goodness
knows where that would end up and you
could imagine there's and clearly tobias
elwood believes this is the case that
were the west to make such a move and to
put its forces in this country willing
and ready to take that risk of a direct
confrontation with russia that that
would be enough to make president putin
blink but what if he didn't if he didn't
then the the results the ramifications
of that really do and i don't want to
use this word um
glibly really do sort of take the entire
world closer to a new world to a third
to the third world war which is clearly
what everybody is trying ultimately to
prevent it's really difficult but what
is true is that the steps that allies
have taken so far in terms of laying out
the the kinds of sanctions that they
would impose on president putin the
bolstering of nato forces
along its eastern flank clearly hasn't
been enough to make president putin
think twice and that's very clear by the
fact that you've got this uh this
so-called drawdown of russian forces
actually looking more like a draw up
okay thank you thanks a lot
still to come on the program for you
this morning with yet another round of
university strikes underway we speak to
the head of the university and college
union and one of the thousands of
students that have been impacted
also speaking to the shadow
international trade secretary nick
thomas simmons coming up
and then later speaking to mark voyager
a former advisor whose knowledge of
russia helped him advise both the us
army and nato
broad mix of stories on the front pages
for you this morning the foreign
secretary liz trust writes for the
telegraph suggesting russian president
vladimir putin will deliberately prolong
the conflict in ukraine in an attempt to
test the mettle of the west
financial times reports that france is
calling for an overhaul of eu security
protocols to counter the threat of
russia
the guardian leads with the news that
all children 5 to 11 will be offered a
kovid jab and has a dramatic picture of
storm dudley hitting the coast
the metro reports on what it calls
another royal scandal the police
investigation into allegations of cash
for honours at one of prince charles's
charities
teachers have been given new guidance on
remaining politically impartial in the
classroom and not to promote movements
like black lives matter
madeleine is joining us now uh from the
newsroom with the timetable hello to you
uh madeline tell us more about this
story
this new department for education
guidance is not what it is not it says
about preventing topics being discussed
or taught in the classroom it's about
reminding teachers to do it with
impartiality an example it gives is when
teaching about racism not to promote the
organization black lives matter or
saving discussions about the sometimes
complex legacy of historic of historical
figures involved in the empire for older
pupils this is what the edu education
secretary nadim saharwi said i don't
want there to be any barriers real or
perceived to teach us vital work in this
space which is why i'm
reinforcing that no subject is off
limits in the classroom as long as it is
treated in an age-appropriate way with
sensitivity and respect and without
promoting contested theories as fact now
it's important to note that is already
illegal this is not a new law it's been
illegal for decades to promote
political theory or partisan views in
the classroom and unions point that out
and say this is what they're already
doing this new guidance just makes
things more complicated more complex for
them and risks stifling engagement in
the classroom with pupils
okay thanks madeline
a group of cross-party mps is calling
for post office workers who were falsely
accused of fraud to be fully compensated
more than 700 people who ran post
offices were wrongfully
prosecuted because of a computing error
it's been described as one of the
biggest miscarriages of justice in
british legal history here's katie
barnfield
hundreds of lives destroyed the post
office staff wrongly convicted for theft
and false accounting lost jobs went to
jail became bankrupt
now a group of cross party mps has
criticized the way the government is
handling compensation for these victims
caught up in one of the biggest
miscarriages of justice in british
history our report today is calling for
full fair and final compensation for
every victim of the post office horizon
scandal now ministers in the post office
have said that they agree but at the
moment the chancellor hasn't signed the
check to pay the bill
and the schemes are not open to all of
the victims who need access
more than 700 post office staff were
wrongly prosecuted after errors in a
computer system called horizon showed up
cash shortfalls that didn't exist after
they were accused some took their own
lives others spent years trying to pay
back money they never owed the report is
particularly critical of the
compensation paid to the group of 555
subpostmasters who originally brought
this case to court because of legal fees
they've lost out on a huge proportion of
the damages they've been awarded the
committee say the government should
cover those costs
chris head was one of those five five
five his life ruined when he was accused
of stealing more than 88 000 pounds from
his branch in west bolden we're not
asking for anything that we're not
entitled to you know we're not asking
for them to give us something that's
that's not deserved
we're asking to be put back into the
financial position we would have been in
had we not encountered the horizon
scandal at all
the inquiry into the scandal continues
this week and while the government
haven't yet announced further
compensation
they say they are keen for all the
issues surrounding it to be resolved
katie barnfield sky news
talking about that in more detail later
on the programme also making news for
you this hour germany has announced
plans to end most of the country's
coronavirus restrictions by the 20th of
march with new infections falling a
three-step plan to start easing rules
was endorsed by the chancellor olaf
schultz
almost 6 million children in the uk aged
5 to 11 are to be offered covered
vaccinations the government's vaccine
advisory committee says children should
be offered a low dose on a non-urgent
basis with a row light in england
expected to start in april
a study published in the british medical
journal has concluded that people who
catch covid19 are more likely to develop
depression and anxiety researchers
compared data for more than 150 000
people who had experienced symptoms with
more than half a million who had not
a coalition of 18 health charities is
calling on the government to continue to
provide free covered tests for everybody
there's some speculation that the
government's living with coveted
strategy for england will lead to an end
to free pcr and lateral flow tests
hong kong's zero covid strategy is being
put to the test hospitals are
overwhelmed following record infection
numbers leaving some patients to be
treated on trolleys in car parks in the
open air our asia correspondent tom
cheshire has this report
two years into the pandemic what's
happening in hong kong looks more like
the first two months
patients wheeled out onto the street as
hospital capacity is overwhelmed
the city's dynamic zero covert strategy
is failing and it's bracing for the
worst
as far as hong kong is concerned we need
to find our own way out of this epidemic
it has
outgrown our capacity
hong kong has been closed off from the
world since the start of the pandemic
it had done well as a result recording
just over 200 deaths with a series of
partial lockdowns and restrictions on
gatherings
the city bought itself time but it did
not spend it well ahead of omicron's
arrival
the vaccination rate among the elderly
is very low and hospitals have been
overwhelmed because mild and even
asymptomatic covert cases must be sent
there
they actually don't need any medical uh
health
but
people who are just panicking they are
panicking because um because there are
so many of them thousands
so we could not we just could not
accommodate them in the hospitals
hong kong has trod a middle path between
the western and chinese approaches to
lockdown
now it seems to have the worst of both
worlds and will have to choose one
definitively
chinese president xi jinping has made a
rare public statement to order that the
overriding mission for hong kong's
leaders is to stabilize the outbreak
that suggests the ultra strict lockdowns
of the mainland may be enforced on the
city
as the western world emerges from the
coveted storm hong kong is right in its
middle
tom cheshire sky news beijing
also making news for you this morning
the nhs and prostate cancer uk are
launching a nationwide campaign to
identify men with prostate cancer amid
fears that more than 14 000 cases may
have gone undetected since the start of
the pandemic
15 year old camilla vallieva is the
favorite to win the women's figure
skating final at the winter olympics
today the russian was cleared to compete
in beijing despite a failed drugs test
she's currently in first place but
there'll be no medal ceremony if she
makes the top three until her case is
concluded
when you're a kid watching the olympics
you get inspired by what's out there
and now it's okay you get inspired by
what's out there but you're also seeing
this
spectacle that is covering up all of the
skating magnificence that could be
seen at at the olympics and it just
feels like
there's an effect potentially on the on
the next generation of skaters
australian police have closed more than
a dozen beaches around sydney after a
swimmer was killed in the city's first
deadly shark attack in nearly 60 years
a warning that we're about to show you
footage of the attack that some viewers
may find distressing
big great white that's a great white
oh man oh no
oh no
emergency services were called to little
bay beach after reports of the attack
but paramedics were unable to save the
victim who is yet to be named
this has been a complete shock for our
community our coastline is our backyard
and to have a tragic death
under such horrifying circumstances is
you know completely shocking it was
surreal sort of like you know no idea
what happened and why or what and then
little by little started coming up on
the news and i went back this morning
malabar is dead there's not even one
person in the water and i'm certainly
not going in for a while
conservation charity warning of a
growing threat to the global whale
population
here we go a report from wwf is calling
for action by countries to protect
so-called whale superhighways used by
the mammals it's a great
image doesn't it that it conjures
superhighways for whales uh creating
them in some of our major oceans the
findings draw on satellite tracking data
from 845 whales over the last 30 years
and highlight significant threats to
their safety most notably fishing net
entanglement their chief marine advisor
says they must be protected at all costs
what we've learned is the it's it's not
good just to protect whales in one place
where they congregate you have to
protect them the full length of their
migration route because they're
experiencing threats all along it and
and that's kind of
shows what what the what the ecosystem
function is
because
uh it has to mix in with the with the
global the globalness of what whales do
quick look as uh the weather here in the
uk it's a bit rougher
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
storm dudley has moved on but to the
southwest stormy eunice is heading in
for tonight and friday the met office
has issued warnings for wind and snow
through to friday evening and there are
similar warnings for ireland
still quite windy and it's cold for most
with showers running into the north and
west there's some more prolonged snow
for the highlands the morning looks fine
for many although there'll be showers
around
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
here's a video showing the power of the
wind during last night's stormy ready
have a look at these fast-moving clouds
against the full moon during storm
dudley a beautiful sight if you were
willing to brave the elements or you
could watch it through the window not so
much if you were outside lightning bolts
have hit an erupting volcano in southern
italy as well mount etna is europe's
highest and most active volcano the
photographer who captured this rare
image said he checks the direction of
the wind and never gets too close
how about this for you morning what the
dog walker has been caught in a
sandstorm at port stewart strand in
county derry the picture was captured as
storm dudley hit northern ireland
yesterday
and what about this for you thursday
morning
a chicken
riding a pig
francisco apparently the vietnamese
potbellied pig has found a new best pal
in battery hen alice the four-year-old
was initially given as a micro pig gift
to a girl but grew too big and got
re-homed in lanarkshire he shares the
house with four dogs and 60 hens and
having kept chickens for quite a long
time all i would say is all lovely but
whatever you do when it's bedtime don't
leave them together otherwise you'll be
missing one chicken now in a moment
we'll speak to the head of the
university and college union joe grady
with yet another round of strikes
[Music]
tomorrow with us in just a moment first
our top stories for you this morning
thousands have suffered power outages
and many trains remain suspended after
storm dudley swept across the uk with
winds topping more than 100 miles an
hour bracing ourselves now for storm
eunice and hospitals in hong kong were
struggling to cope with the surge in new
covey cases with some patients being
treated on trolleys in car parks
the us says russia has moved as many as
7 000 more troops to the border with
ukraine contradicting moscow's claim
that they were withdrawing some forces
the latest was hearing is that there's
also maneuvers in the baltic sea as we
speak
well in the last hour i spoke to the
defense committee chair tobias elwood he
told me the consequences of not
preventing a russia attack would be
grave
i think privately the international
community is regretting not stepping
forward but we still can act we still
can offer a no-fly zone and critically
this initiative that britain has put
forward the last time the prime minister
was here this alliance between poland
ukraine and britain is something that's
very very important indeed that needs to
be explored as to how we can support the
ukrainian people if we do nothing and
allow an invasion to take place it will
have i think a totemic effect on
european security this is a serious
moment and we're being tested
wallace um tomorrow's here ben wallace
uh speaking at nato just uh at the
moment we'll bring that to our viewers
in just a second or two thoughts good
morning morning well tobias elwood says
we are being tested and actually that's
the government's message as well this
truss is flying to the region today she
says that vladimir putin may hold off on
in invading or attacking ukraine for
weeks or months and this is a test of
the west's mettle now tobias elwood
takes a different view he's the chair of
the defense committee saying that in the
meantime the west should go further he
had been calling for western troops to
actually enter ukraine although that was
not a view shared in government who said
that ukraine are not a member of nato
therefore that wouldn't be happening and
he says that will be too late now but we
should perhaps look at a no-fly zone of
the sort that the west brought in over
libya in 2011.
now the government's view is that that's
not what they're going to do they're
going to bolster the countries on
ukraine's borders but i think they agree
with him that this is a serious test the
route they want to go down is sanctions
and liz trust is warning today she's
going to be giving a keynote speech in
eastern europe today that russia faces
massive economic consequences he thinks
that uh that might be actually
counterproductive okay let's sanction
russia i'm sorry to interrupt uh let's
hear what ben wallace has to say
well i think there's quite a lot of as
they say in russia
going on uh you know i think we have
seen the opposite of some of the
statements we've seen a increase of
troops over the last 48 hours up to 7
000. we've seen a bridge constructed
from belarus
into ukraine or near ukraine and i think
we should as i've said we'll take them
at their word but we're going to judge
russia by their actions and at the
moment the troop buildup continues your
build-up continues too you've just sent
more troops more equipment to estonia
isn't that just going to antagonize the
russians at a time when you say you want
donald trump not at all look what we're
trying to say to russia is the
consequences of this mass buildup nearly
60 percent of russia's land combat
forces on the border of a sovereign
nation will get you the opposite effect
in 2014 when you illegally invaded
ukraine uh and crimea you ended up with
more troops on your borders more defense
spending uh throughout nato that's what
will happen that's the strategic error
uh that uh putin is potentially about to
make if he does invade and i think it's
really important that he understands
that nato is completely united on this
we are deadly serious in how we're going
to face the threat that is currently
being posed to both ukraine and
potentially to our security and that's
why we've been here today and yesterday
making sure that we are all in step
which we are to make sure the message is
clear to the kremlin
the nato defense nato secretary
yesterday
talked about
the biggest crisis in europe since the
end of the cold war and that this is a
normal is this a new normal building up
troops on either side and facing each
other off
well i think what is certainly becoming
tragically normal is the kremlin using
malign activity and threats to try and
get its way and we've seen that both in
the physical invasion of crimea
and the occupation of that part of
ukraine we've seen that right now with a
hundred you know fifty thousand plus
troops on the border of a sovereign
state you know that is not normal in
anybody else's book of course nato has
to respond to that of course europe has
to respond to that uh you know this is
not a a joke or a light matter this is a
a real challenge to the stability of
europe and one of the ways we can make
sure there is no overspill or escalation
is to provide resilience to our partners
at nato and that's what we're all doing
anybody else taking them at the word
judging them by their actions that's
right and the clear message from the
nato secretary general from our
government from the u.s government is
that what russia says in terms of
showing us those pictures of tanks
withdrawing does not accord with what's
happening on the ground they see
evidence of a military buildup as we can
see from saw from some of those
satellite pictures and that's what we
should be looking at interesting crunch
point might come on sunday the 20th k
when russia had said that its military
exercises in belarus where part of the
troop build-up is would come to an end
so we'll see if that makes any
difference okay tomorrow thank you
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock thank
you now more than 50 000 staff at
universities across the country are on
strike once again in a long-running
dispute over pensions pay and working
conditions ten days of strike action
kicked off on monday joined by joe grady
the general secretary of the university
and college union which represents more
than 120 000 academic staff hello to you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
on the program this morning tell us
about the action being taken
yeah so um as you said the strike action
this week and as of monday staff at 68
universities will be taking strike
action and this is over pay which has
fallen by 20 in the last 12 years it's
about a 35 cut and to staff's guaranteed
pension
but it's also as you said about working
conditions so we are seeing
an absolute explosion of workloads at
universities and recent reports suggest
staff half the staff are showing signs
of probable depression but we've also
seen institutions um making serious
misuse of zero hour contracts we've got
over 66 000 staff on some form of
casualized or atypical contract and this
is increasing and of course all of this
is against the fact that inflation has
soared by 7.8
there is a huge cost of living crisis
staff have moved heaven and earth
throughout this pandemic to do
everything they can for students
and it's so disappointing we're back
here but staff deserve so much better
which how many universities have been uh
affected and what's the mood
so this week there's 44 next week
because the pay dispute will will kick
in as well it's 68 and the mood on
picket lines is i think as it always is
um frustrated
um
upbeat despite the terrible weather that
we've had and also um staff and students
standing firmly together 73 of students
um support the strikes i've been
visiting picket lines in in glasgow and
yorkshire and london
and people are just as determined as
ever because this isn't a sector that is
cash strapped if we look at the total
income across the sex last year it was
41.9 billion it has reserves of 46.8
billion this is a strategic decision
that university managers are taking
and so nobody wants to be on the picket
lines but it's certainly not a defeated
attitude
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the programme while hundreds of
thousands of students are being impacted
as you can imagine by the strikes let's
hear from one of them uh harry baldwin a
third year student at the university of
york hi harry what are you reading
hi um to be honest students at the
moment are just quite angry they're
quite disappointed and they feel like
they've been um taken for a ride almost
you know we've been facing such large
amounts of disruption now for a long
period of time with the strikes the
covered pandemic and we're disappointed
by it all of course
what impact is it having on you
well we're missing out on large amounts
of learning but also the personal
element as well so back in december when
the strikes were announced
my assessments were brought forward for
the strikes and my name was very
unfortunately unwell in hospital and i
contacted one of my university lecturers
who i said you know is it possible if i
were to go home and see my nan and
unfortunately she never got back to me
and i had to do my assessments a week
early and i never saw my nana again so
it's having a very big personal impact
at the moment on students
oh i'm sorry to hear that that's
terrible um
the impact on online learning as opposed
to in-person learning for you
i think it's not the same whatsoever you
know we're expected to pay the same
amount in tuition and we're not getting
the same service whatsoever from us but
one thing i really want to mention here
is i think there's an alternative method
to striking here so jay was talking
about picket lines and university
lectures and academics going out on
strike well actually there's an
alternative method they could be
pursuing which would reduce disruption
to students so i was talking to on the
uc one ucu members yesterday and they
were saying to me one of the alternative
strike methods is to reduce research for
the university which would impact their
financial uh cost to the university as
well as reducing grand
applications which would have a
financial implication to the university
while reducing the disruption to
university students and i think that
would be a better option to be pursued
by the union
from your perspective how much support
is there uh for this
this series of strikes which will
increase still further next week
i don't think there's that much support
whatsoever you know i've spoken to a lot
of uh university students across the
last few days about this and they're
just fed up and they're tired of it all
you know
being a third year student myself we've
faced two and a half years of strikes
now we've faced um kobe pandemic we've
gone through so much we've missed out so
much of our learning i just feel like
there could be so much more done in
order to help university students out
during this situation
what is it that you're studying so i'm
studying at social and political
sciences so a large amount of my
lecturers are currently um striking
unfortunately but one thing that really
irritates me is quite a few of them have
actually taken down their online
resources so i'm unable to use those
during my um
during the strike break or the strike
recess
that's annoying um what are you hoping
to do
career-wise once you leave university
well i'm quite fortunate i've been
offered a grand job already uh compared
to quite a lot of other people so i'm
moving to scotland in a few months so
i'm looking forward to that
oh can you tell us what you're going to
do
so i'll be working uh for cgi as a
business graduate
oh show off good for you fantastic i
hope that you managed to get this sorted
and that you managed to finish your um
studies in a timely fashion thanks very
much indeed for joining us
thank you all the best thank you very
much you too thank you young man let's
speak now to the shadow international
trade secretary nick thomas simmons
hello t thanks for joining us just a
quick thought on that while we've got
you i know that you can turn your hand
to anything
do the lectures striking have your
support
well first dk it's great to join you uh
this morning and good morning to you
with regard to the situation at our
universities i would just urge everybody
concerned to get round the table and to
find a solution
of course nobody wants to see a
situation where people go out on strike
whether it's the people going on strike
themselves the managers in our
universities or indeed the students i
think our
our university sector has been through
an extraordinarily difficult period in
the pandemic students staff facing
enormous challenges i very much hope
that a solution to this can be
found so that staff can resume their
work and students can resume their
education
is the government doing enough as far as
money laundering is concerned as it's
been described by um british the people
who are british they've got a british
passport but they are either dual
nationality or originally from russia
the government is not doing enough and
there are a number of promises the
government has made to look at issues
and it simply hasn't done it so the the
so-called go golden visas for example
where if people show they have
millions to invest in the united kingdom
they are they are simply allowed in
without those checks the government has
been looking at that issue i think for
the best part of four years now and
hasn't actually acted upon it the
government has been promising an
economic crime uh bill then we hear that
it isn't necessarily coming forward in
this parliamentary session because we
need to see uh reform we need to see
transparency so for example we have a
company's house that quite rightly
registers companies but we've got
companies that are at what
shell companies they're companies within
companies we don't actually know
who the beneficial owners are and we
need to be doing more too to crack down
on the laundromat of dirty money that
exists in this country there are huge
amounts the government should be doing
and they should be doing it now
um talk to me about
your reaction to this research that
we've been seeing from
the british chambers of commerce are
surveying a thousand businesses um and
they are saying only one in eight said
that um the brexit trade deal was
helping their business
yes and over 70 percent were raising
problems with the trade and cooperation
agreement and the reality is that this
government is not making brexit work and
it needs to do two absolutely critical
things firstly it needs to look at
making pragmatic changes to the trading
cooperation agreement itself that will
make it easier for our businesses to
import and export up and down the
country but second what what is really
crucial from the british chambers of
commerce research indeed from what i've
spoken to exporters too is the
government just isn't providing the
support that's required that that
research from british chambers of
commerce shows that the businesses most
affected are small and medium-sized
businesses with 250 employees or less
who don't have the resources to go out
and employ trade advisors so when the
government is actually looking at the
changes coming in so we had additional
customs checks for example come in on
new year's day this year the government
needs to step up and provide support to
businesses to be able to adjust at the
moment the government is just standing
on the sidelines and not giving our
exports the support they need
they're certainly focusing on what's
happening as far as covid is concerned
um and it does look as though um
whatever covert restrictions are left in
place they could be scrapped completely
uh by the end of this month most
certainly if not before then uh
including these free lateral flow tests
is that a good idea
no that's the wrong decision at the
wrong time the government should not be
scrapping the free lateral flow test
they are
extraordinarily useful and important
what if for example you have people who
are going to visit
a vulnerable elderly relative perhaps
even visiting someone in a care home
perhaps visiting someone who has an
underlying condition the use of those
lateral flow tests is absolutely crucial
i think the government is making a
profound mistake
in taking away the free availability of
those tests
okay um
just looking at uh i mean i saw images
there are people having lateral flows of
course that's what so many of us um are
used to doing do you not feel that you
know we it is time now for us to get
back to normal which is what the
government is saying and even if you do
have a positive test
in all likelihood you you won't have to
self-isolate going forward
well what i want to see on the issue of
the self-isolation rules is the actual
evidence that the government is using to
support that decision parliament will be
sitting again next week i hope the
government will put that evidence
forward of course we want to see
restrictions disappear on our lives we
all want to see that we all want to move
on we've had this two years of
incredible disruption and sacrifice but
trust is so low in this prime minister
that we have to see a transparent
decision-making process where we can see
the reasons these decisions are made
because the worry with this prime
minister at the moment doing anything
and everything to save his own job is
he's appeasing his own backbenchers and
not taking decisions based on the
science let's actually see the science
and the evidence the decision is based
on i think that will assist everyone
with trust going forward
good to talk to you thank you so much
for taking the time thank you
quick look at the weather for you
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
storm dudley has moved through but the
southwest storm eunice is heading in for
tonight and for friday the met office
has issued warnings for wind and snow
through to friday evening and there are
similar warnings for ireland still quite
windy out there today so be careful if
you're heading out and about
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so obviously with all that wind around
the last place you want to be is on an
airplane isn't it trying to come in to
land
look away now
if you have a fear of flying
spare a thought for the pilot and crew
from the northwest regiment of the
national police air service
coming in to land a very
bumpy flight during storm dudley as you
can see it may look scary but the
service says safety is their top
priority and wouldn't fly if it wasn't
safe there are wind limits for takeoff
and landing but not once airborne if
you've ever been on an airplane as it's
trying to land in the middle of a wind a
a storm then
you probably won't want to do it again
trust me